Angelina Jolie is back for Disney's Maleficent
sequel that continues to rewrite the story
of Sleeping Beauty's iconic villain.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing and explaining twelve
incredible easter eggs and details you might
have missed in Maleficent: Mistress of Evil.
There will be spoilers, so take care if you
haven't seen the film yet.
At the beginning of the new movie, we find
Aurora surrounded by her fairy subjects, conducting
business as Queen of the Moors.
The three pixies though have devised a secret
plan to lure her to a surprise meeting with
Prince Phillip.
Pinto steals Aurora's crown and with the help
of the other magical creatures, she leads
her through the forest to a spot where Phillip
is waiting to propose to Aurora.
The moment is a fun twist of sorts on the
Once Upon A Dream scene from Sleeping Beauty
where the princess's animal friends secretly
stole Phillip's clothes and led him to her.
There's also a little nod to Aurora and Phillip's
dance in Once Upon A Dream, when in the new
movie Phillip and Aurora embrace and spin
around after she accepts his proposal.
There's another homage to a memorable moment
from Disney's classic animation during Aurora's
wedding ceremony when the two pixies Knotgrass
and Thistlewit [aka the Red and Green fairies]
use magic to change the colour of Aurora's
wedding dress and argue over whether pink
or green looks better.
This is a cute call-back to when the Red and
Blue Fairies, Flora and Merryweather, argued
over the colour of Aurora's sixteenth birthday
dress
"Make it pink."
"Make it blue!"
"Pink!"
In Mistress of Evil, their argument over the
dress comes to an end when the dress turns
blue and the two pixies turn to the blue flower
next to them, which is their fallen friend
Flittle, and they both say the colour is perfect.
Many fans were disappointed that in her first
live-action movie Maleficent didn't transform
into a dragon as she had done in Disney's
original animated Sleeping Beauty, but instead
turned Diaval into a dragon instead.
The filmmakers seem to have taken note of
that for the sequel by creating a scene where
Maleficent rises from the ashes as an enormous
dark phoenix, in a moment that recalls her
animated dragon transformation.
"Now shall you deal with me, O Prince.
And all the powers of hell!"
Just before that moment, Maleficent appeared
to die when she was hit by a poisoned bolt
from Ingrith's crossbow which turned her to
dust a la Infinity War.
But when Aurora's tears of sorrow fell on
Maleficent's ashes, it sparked the resurrection
of her surrogate mother who as the last of
the Phoenix's descendants has the power of
death and rebirth.
Aurora's tears helping to bring back her mother
figure is also a nice nod to and a reverse
of how Maleficent's kiss saved Aurora from
the sleeping curse in the first film.
There's another call-back to the first Maleficent
movie in the scene after Phillip presents
Aurora with a Tomb Bloom flower, and Aurora
goes off to investigate where the flower came
from.
After she discovers Queen Ingrith's secret
door and stairway into the castle basement,
Aurora hears voices whispering to her which
lead her yet again to the cursed spinning
wheel, just like they did in the first film.
"[Whispering voices] Aurora..
.. on the spindle of a spinning wheel."
Of course, after Aurora pricked her finger
on the spindle in Sleeping Beauty, Maleficent
appeared and uttered her famous line:
"You poor, simple fools.
Thinking you could defeat me!
Me!
The mistress of all evil!"
That title "Mistress of all evil" ended up
as the basis of the title for this Maleficent
sequel.
But what's especially interesting is that
despite Maleficent's villainous reputation
being redeemed in the first movie, over the
five years that followed, Queen Ingrith spread
malicious rumours about her in order to foment
mistrust and suspicion between the human and
fairy populations.
In this live-action universe, Disney's animated
version of the Sleeping Beauty fairy tale
is like a fake story that Ingrith made up.
"I remember the story of an evil witch.
And the princess she cursed to sleep forever.
The story became legend.
But this is no fairy tale."
And given everything else Ingrith does, in
this film she's the queen who really deserves
the title "Mistress of Evil".
In a perhaps surprising moment for a family-focussed
film, Queen Ingrith together with her henchwoman
goes as far as to orchestrate a Game of Thrones
Red Wedding-style scene.
After the Moor-folk are led into the castle's
church for Aurora and Phillip's wedding ceremony,
Ingrith gives the order for her evil sidekick
to release the deadly red iron dust to kill
all the fairies inside.
"Start the music."
It's a scene that brings to mind the notorious
Red Wedding from Game of Thrones with the
queen's guards even barricading the fairy
guests inside the building to stop them from
escaping the lethal toxins.
And during the attempted church massacre Pixie
Flittle sacrificed herself to protect the
other trapped creatures when she flew into
the organ and, after being hit by a ball of
red powder, was transformed into an enormous
bloom of blue flowers that blocked the organ
pipes, stopping the release of any more toxic
powder.
The way that Flittle and many other fairies
turned into flowers or other flora whenever
they were hit by the red iron powder reminded
me of the scene in Sleeping Beauty where the
Red Fairy transformed the arrows from Maleficent's
goons into harmless flowers.
One of the Moors' Tree Warriors also sacrificed
himself in the church by using his branches
to cover and protect the other fairy creatures
from the poisonous powder exploding all around
them.
It may or may not be deliberate, but the moment
feels like a nod to Marvel's Groot and, spoiler
for the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie,
how he sacrificed himself by shielding the
other Guardians with his branches when Ronan's
ship was crash-landing to the ground.
"We
are
Groot."
By the way, Queen Ingrith seems to be inspired
by an interesting character from one of the
early Sleeping Beauty fairy tales.
There are two parts to Charles Perrault's
version of the story from the late 17th century.
In the first part, a wicked fairy is the villain,
but in the second part, the prince's mother,
known as the Ogress Queen Mother, is the antagonist,
and as her name suggests she's a terribly
evil character, who like Michelle Pfeiffer's
Queen Ingrith, tries but fails to kill off
her daughter-in-law, sleeping beauty.
There's also a few interesting fashion-related
easter eggs that the sequel's designers purposely
included in Maleficent 2.
Aurora's blue dress that she wears at the
beginning of the movie as Queen of the Moors
and the pink dress she later wears to her
engagement dinner were both deliberately chosen
by the movie's costume designer as tributes
to Aurora's pink and blue dresses from Sleeping
Beauty.
And because Elle Fanning who plays Aurora
wanted a little added something that specifically
paid homage to the animated film, a Sleeping
Beauty collar was added to Aurora's pink engagement
dress.
And Maleficent's costume at the beginning
of the movie with its "green[ish] colour [and]
subtle reptile pattern" also tips its hat
to her animated dragon form and its green
eyes and firey breath.
"Don't..
ruin my morning."
And there's a fun double easter egg when Aurora
argues with Maleficent about her upcoming
marriage to Phillip,
"What's next?
You'll turn him into a goat?"
That line pays off later when Maleficent turns
the defeated evil queen Ingrith into a goat.
"Oh, come on, that's funny."
But it's also a reference to the animated
design of Maleficent's horns which were based
on goat horns.
So did you spot any other easter eggs or interesting
details in the Maleficent sequel?
And what were your favourite moments?
Share your thoughts in the comments and don't
forget to subscribe and hit the Gleam link
below for a chance to win an awesome Maleficent
Funko Pop.
The giveaway runs for the next four weeks
and the winner will be contacted via email.
Next tap left to watch my Disney playlist
or tap right for something else you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!